you went to some sort of acting school
you gotta get $3,500 a gift for in your
grandmother's will
yeah and you put it toward acting
lessons yeah when you went you said you
were like the worst I was which is so
important for people to hear in other
words you say if you work it out yeah
you can actually learn to be an actor
it's a skill 100% right but you got to
be all in yeah I was all and it was what
I wanted to do and I went through yeah
cuz I must have been only because it was
really shitty for those first few months
you know when there's a smell about you
like the teacher this main teacher was
like I hate this guy right
and he's terrible and he just snuck into
this course like he got in off the bench
that's how they viewed you right and
then all the other you know they're all
nice to me but the other students are
kind of like not hanging with that I
remember this is a lot of great that you
succeeded and they didn't because I felt
that with other announcers when I first
started they would look at me like I was
the biggest douchebag loser like this
guy's going nowhere
right and it kind of gave me a thrill as
I went on in my career and got more and
more well-known and writing and
successful yeah I was like hey [ __ ] you
guys I kind of made it no one believed
in me it does kind of give you an
impetus to go on doesn't it oh yeah yeah
I mean you need something to fight
against one more they always say about
our business it's just people papering
over trauma with a success right there's
you just have to keep feeling that also
yeah and you did all the typical you
work there's a children's party clown
I did everything were you a good clown
uh good up to the age of three so a
three-year-olds birthday pay um I was
the best I you could climb on my head I
could juggle three things I could juggle
kind of anything right like swords
anything two three but nothing more no
balloon animals no magic tricks so a
three-year-old would be entertained by
you 100% and United abilities right and
energetic no problem and you're being
hired so the parents can just drink for
now and I remember the last gig I ever
did an eight-year-olds party you know
that's tough and this I remember the kid
game mom this clown is crap literally
they kid and I looked at my bag and I I
would sometimes juggle an egg and I'd
break it in my hand right
right so I just got out three eggs and
it broke and the kids like whatever and
I ended up with the kids having the eggs
throwing them at me tonight and that was
working they loved it and pilot and
kicking the [ __ ] out of me
talking on top of eating you yeah and I
oh yeah just like I just let him dive on
top and I'm just just arrested leg was
pathetic right but that were happy your
act was getting and I'm looking at my
watch and ten minutes ago and that was
hitting never went back again that was
the end of clowning yeah I mean really I
was crap